i've always felt that it was important
to
escape acting is a pretty weird
profession it keeps celebs on their toes
and their co-stars stepping on them all
the time too unfortunately at that high
of a caliber of work all the shade can
be career-ending and life-altering it
was funny because i had no idea what i
was gonna be playing number one don't
they usually do chemistry tests for
movies the reason for amber heard's
recasting in aquaman 2 has nothing to do
with herd and johnny depp's relationship
and everything to do with jason momoa
having literally no chemistry on set it
took a ton of movie magic good
cinematography lighting and even a solid
score to sell their chemistry because
the actors just did not have it
they come from two different worlds
quite literally number two second-hand
cigarette breath is no joke angelina
jolie was disgusted by johnny depp's
cigarette breath when it came to kissing
him in the tourist and demanded he used
breath mints and listerine before they
locked lips jolie was also disappointed
depp didn't get in better shape for the
role and didn't cut his hair or anything
he would stay in his trailer to avoid
her thinking she was full of herself
it makes me feel unpleasant you know
number three your boss makes a big deal
about just moving you to a different
department hunter schaefer and jacob
allordy seemed inseparable during season
1 of euphoria everything changed between
then and the filming for season 2. the
two actors used to shower each other
with compliments on social media and
then one day boom they weren't even
following each other anymore allegedly
they refused to film scenes together and
i know that must have been like really
hard number four first impressions are
never good because they're never real
the cast of stranger things was in a
honeymoon phase for the first few
seasons but that ended and now they
bicker all the time like siblings david
harbour compared the cast to a very
dysfunctional family there's a lot of
drama but it never gets cruel charlie
and i can't look at each other it's bad
number five we're not cutting the check
until these two set aside their
differences tom holland believes his
fake feud with anthony mackie began
during captain america civil war i don't
know if you've been in a fight before
but there's usually not this much talk
tom stole anthony's classic line cut the
check this is a line mackie says when he
deems a shot was perfect oh that was
good
[Applause]
the two are constantly teasing and
poking fun at each other but they have
stressed that they are good friends
mackie would joke that holland would
need frequent juice breaks and
babysitters to keep him in check in one
interview maki said he never saw tom's
movie spider-man homecoming and tom got
him good firing back i haven't seen the
falcon one oh no wait there isn't one
i'm sorry while we might not get a
falcon movie we gotta say we sure are
excited about the fourth captain america
we're dealing with him over at marvel
accordingly because he's a problem
number six it's best to keep your
opinions to yourself
jonah hill didn't think christopher
mintz was very professional right from
the superbad auditions because the actor
was all over jonah's lines after chris
left jonah told casting
not that guy and unfortunately for him
that made casting want the actor even
more they eventually got past this and
both went on to voice characters
snotlout and fishlegs in how to train
your dragon number 7. this is a prime
example of words having power when
hubert got pregnant her onset
personality changed she was struggling
financially at home then her salary was
cut and there was plenty of conflict
between her and will smith so she chose
to leave the fresh prince of bel air but
will made it sound like janet was fired
for being hard to work with which tanked
her career she was adamant she would
never do a reunion saying he is still an
egomaniac and has not grown up but now
that he's grown she's finally got to
tell will what he'd done and how it made
her feel which left him regret filled
with tears in his eyes but i felt it was
necessary for us to finally
move forward
yeah
number eight these two were just fated
to fight in the fate of the furious
dwayne johnson thinks vin diesel didn't
act very professionally on set johnson
and diesel have fundamental differences
in philosophies on how they approach
movie making and collaborating still
love each other that's my boy number
nine sometimes opposites attract the
worst oscars hosting in the world was
done by anne hathaway and james franco
we're both nominated
uh
actually james i'm not nominated tonight
come on anne don't be so modest hathaway
originally turned the gig down but
franco convinced her to do it their
complete opposite personality types made
them clash on stage she came prepared he
did not it used to be
you get naked you get nominated
she did liken herself to a slightly
manic cheerleader so it isn't all
franco's fault but well after it was
over she was thinking you gotta be
kidding me your first instinct is
usually the right one all the reasons
she initially turned the role down came
true and franco doesn't seem to like
anne hathaway because she's too
scripted number 10 while they were
inseparable confidants in the city
offset that was not the case the end
just like that revival of sex in the
city was pretty much a recycled version
of the third film that never got done a
film that kim cattrall turned down in
2016 because she found the script wasn't
very good there was nothing of interest
for her character kim wasn't asked to be
part of the show and she is more than
fine with that after being so open with
her feelings in the past about sarah
jessica parker she criticized parker on
social media for showing fake sympathy
when someone she'd cared about passed
away an attempt to use this moment to
repair her image i don't know i found it
very upsetting number 11. the whole
universe was in a hot dense state thanks
to these two the big bang theory stars
kaylee cuoco and johnny galecki dated
for a bit but kaylee was quick to move
on from johnny to a new equestrian bow
and didn't shy away from bringing him to
set or making this relationship well
known this created a rift in kaley and
johnny's work relationship number 12.
turns out growing up in st thomas
ontario doesn't mean you'll get along
great on set ryan gosling was the one in
charge of casting his love interest and
he just found he had absolutely no
chemistry with rachel mcadams and he
made a fool of her in her audition in
front of her face about them having no
chemistry this behavior persisted on set
then one day the two dated they're gonna
look really bad at the end of this this
isn't gonna turn out well for us number
13 there was a stark conflict between
these two terence howard vouched for rdj
to get the role of iron man and that was
an uphill battle given they weren't
willing to look past robert's addiction
howard even took a one million dollar
pay cut to get his friend in the door
but when terence fell on hard times rdj
wasn't there to back him up so terence
blames rdj for why he's no longer
involved in the mcu i think they could
have a huge franchise off of it but
number 14. the communication between
these two was a wasteland tom hardy and
charlize theron didn't get along while
filming mad max fury road because they
were stuck together filming in a vehicle
that was going to no particular
destination the tight quarters made
filming super uncomfortable and fighting
inevitable theron said it was like a
family road trip that just never went
anywhere number 15. the sparknotes
version of star-crossed lovers in romeo
and juliet claire danes was the serious
one and her co-star leonardo dicaprio
liked to mess around but that doesn't
mean they despised each other no not at
all claire had a crush on dicaprio and
also impressed him when in her audition
she didn't play the shy and sweet juliet
everyone thinks of her and instead
grabbed leo by the back of the neck and
planted one on him she was just like
hardcore about the whole thing so it was
cool everybody loves a good celebrity
feud we bet you've had a co-worker who's
gotten under your skin let us know your
crazy experiences with them in the
comments and uh maybe leave names out of
it thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things